[Musik]
er ist gerade 9 uhr ein und erhalten so
nah und ich habe mich behalten und auf
meiner gruppe den ball ab und dann
fangen wir alle die wir uns noch die
entweder noch mit endlich fünf personen
die mit einer parade am freitag schaut
ich bin am abend hunderte aufnehmen und
genau und friedensforscher am donnerstag
ich werde auf der autobahn hinter deiner
genommen wird auf der bank sein werde
und daher genau heute auch die privat
steinen lerne ich bin einfach mein
manager retten werden sollen ich bin
gleich auf der außenbahn aber urlaub zu
fliegen kannst du für mich die garderobe
kaufen
ich habe mal wieder super gepackt und
zwar nicht irgendeinen gegenstand genau
hier drauf liegt dann
geht einfach mal probieren bevor auf den
weg begeben bevor erholt und hat
besondere auf ästhetik befinden wir
fahren jetzt einen kollegen aus bonn
abholen der leider fehlt mir die zum
träumen an der stelle schau doch am ende
bist du bastard autofahrer oder verraten
scheitere der ganz schön stockender
verkehr
11 und 59 in einer minute klopp die neue
schuhkollektion verbleib im auto über
lte awards zu kriegen
in beidem zahlungsvorgang grad voraus
es ist beim fast food restaurant
angekommen und werden die polizei nicht
essen eigentlich haben wir keine zeit
aber wir am hunger das werdet euch holen
peter berg meine damen und entspannt
dass apple hier mit fährt hin und auch
noch diese kleine große party halloween
eigentlich ein bisschen schlampig
gearbeitet sich da so
ruhig bei sammeln wir haben am start
haben dort freunde wir haben apple und
wärme schaut euch einfach diese
schönheit an über all das schöne mehr
oder etwas dagegen
[Musik]
ich habe übrigens seit längerer zeit
einen eigenen weg durch genannten
aufleben
aber ich will jetzt irgendwie in einem
hänger und motorrad und
ich weiß nicht ob ich dumm bin aber ich
glaube dass ich den autofokus kamera
zerstört habe
es ist einfach so gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt stehen erst mal luca hier gegen
apple und der verlierer hat der verein
vor ort machen den anderen bestimmt
[Musik]
das blatt geschrieben der erste der das
kommentierte damen dann sich selber
kommentiert mit hälfte kommentiert auf
jeden fall jetzt hier heute vom ersten
blöcke sind eine mega koma gehalten
lange zu warten und zu lange gebraucht
haben aber trotzdem habe ich mich sehr
freuen und natürlich sagen wir uns
morgen im neuen energie geladen und auch
wieder haut rein und schau
[Musik]